how are you  all right i know we only have a few  seconds but i wrote you a letter okay  okay and now listen this letter i swear  to god it's not a pitch deck it's  nothing like that it's about how you  changed my life but listen not only my  life you changed my little siblings  lives as well you know what i mean  because i'm their older brother i'm  their role model and i went to jail for  two and a half years right when i came  out it was you your videos and your  motivation and that girl right there  that changed my life ultimately and so i  wrote a letter to you so you can get  know a little bit more about me you know  please where is that a lot of time and  effort into that much i'm going to read  it for you all right thank you hey how  you enjoying becoming oh man i love it  you did a sick job  pretty good so far right  [Music]  thank you name william i'm proud of you  where do you live i live on winnipeg  manitoba good for you  [Music]